today on the matt well show in a
disturbing zoom video a public school
teacher tells
other teachers that it's their moral
duty to brainwash
kids into critical race there in fact if
they don't brainwash kids
they're no better than sexual abuser she
says and this kind of madness is all
over the school system which raises the
question i've asked many times
when are we going to abandon the system
entirely if not now when we'll talk
about that also five headlines
including the defund the police
proponent who ended up having to call
the police himself
after some kids stole his car which is
pretty great and caitlyn jenner in a
shocking turn of events
flip-flops and comes out in favor now of
males and female sports plus
a woman writes to slate asking what to
do about her husband
who won't take his take his mask off at
all ever
even while being intimate in our daily
cancellation i will defend myself
against the gay news publication that
is currently trying to cancel and
de-platform me so a little bit of a
reverse cancellation will happen today
that's always exciting all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
finally getting into the summer months
the weather is nice not not weather
isn't very nice today here anyway but
generally it is and uh so what do you
wanna how do you wanna spend your
time this spring and summer do you wanna
spend it in an auto parts store
wandering around looking for auto parts
i don't think anyone does it's not
anyone's idea of a great time at least
it's not mine that's why you need
rockauto.com rockauto.com is
so much easier also more enjoyable than
walking into a
auto parts store and the thing is when
you get there they might not have what
you need
in stock they got to order it online why
go through that whole rigmarole
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
and uh they you know basically their
question is why spend
up to twice as much on the same parts
and for a worse selection there's no
reason to do that
they're a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
so go to rockauto.com to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog is unique and very easy to
navigate even for
an absolute [ __ ] like myself so i know
that you'll do just fine
quickly see all the parts available and
uh so again go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and as always write walsh in
there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you there is
one question that's often posed to me
i'm asked what can we do the culture is
in bad shape lunatics are running the
asylum everything's falling apart
civilization is collapsing around us
darkness covers the land the eye of
sauron gazes down at us
what can we do about it what's the
solution and i'm tempted to say
sometimes that we should just pop open a
beach chair pour some whiskey
watch the apocalypse unfold that would
be the easiest and perhaps most
enjoyable way
to address the problem but it would also
be despair it would be giving up on the
world on our families
on ourselves and so we can't do that or
at least i can't do that
not yet anyway so what's the real
solution
well first we must acknowledge that
there is no one simple solution there
isn't even a guaranteed like five-step
plan
or guide fighting to save western
civilization is not like assembling ikea
furniture
or anyway if the simple solution or plan
exists i don't have it i don't know what
it is
all i know is that we must begin with a
willingness
to make radical changes to our personal
lives
to the way that we live it's not enough
to demand those changes in the world
we have to make them we must be ready to
make significant sacrifices and
completely alter the way we live
on a day-to-day basis if we're content
to float with the cultural tide
generally living
how everybody else lives doing what
everyone else does taking the path of
least resistance and all of that then
there's really no hope now we're back to
the the beach chair and the whiskey
pack it in give up wave the white flag
watch the fireworks from a safe distance
that is until the fireball engulfs you
too which it will eventually
if that doesn't sound appealing then we
have to be willing to live differently
right now one of our great problems as
conservatives are simply as people who
are not radical leftists whatever label
you ascribe to
one of our great problems is that we
don't like the program
that our culture has for us but we tend
to follow it anyway
we aren't willing to sacrifice almost
anything
we won't even change our consumption
habits how many of us have made so much
as
minor changes in our day-to-day lives so
as to live
more in accordance with our values and
principles
i'm sure some people have done that but
i'm guessing the percentage is very low
and that's just not going to work we
become like the morbidly obese
man who wants to figure out a way to
lose weight but without breaking a sweat
or experiencing more than 10 minutes of
hunger it doesn't work
it can't work we have to choose one path
or the other
and that brings me to a familiar drum
that i so often beat um
i'm not saying this is the be-all and
end-all as i already clarified there
isn't any one single solution but this
is a crucial change
we must make we must abandon
the government school system not fix it
not reform it
that's a fool's errand we have to
abandon it get out of it leave it behind
let it collapse there's no other way
this must be one of the first steps
towards any serious effort to save our
civilization if we skip over this step
there's no point in taking any other
steps once again we're back at the beach
chair with the whiskey glass
there's no path to reclaiming the
culture that will allow us to still
send our children into government
indoctrination centers for seven hours a
day
every day for 12 years that path doesn't
exist
case in point the daily caller has this
report quote
an eighth grade teacher from the
beaverton school district in oregon
compared being resistant to actively
teaching anti-racism
to sexually abusing children during a
zoom video call catherine watkins a
humanities teacher
at cedar park middle school was recorded
during a zoom video session telling her
fellow educators
that teachers who are not actively
teaching quote anti-racism
are abusing children now it's even worse
than it sounds and we have the video
let's uh listen
catherine watkins 8th grade humanities
teacher at cedar park middle school
and my pronouns are she her we and us
um i'm going to say something that's not
mine
okay so i i have to stop it just there
for one just one second
uh because we can't we can't skip over
that part
we haven't got to the meat of this thing
yet but we gotta pause for a moment
and think about this her pronouns are
she if i heard that right
i think i heard that right her pronouns
are she her we
and us what
now in a certain way you might say that
everyone's pronouns are we
and us by definition we have all at
various points identified ourselves in a
we or us category but that's exactly why
you don't need to stipulate that it's
like saying that your pronoun is me
of course you're a me everyone's a me
you don't need to say that
but it's even crazier than it first
seems keep in mind that when someone
gives you their pronouns
they're telling you what pronouns you
can use
in reference to them she and her
are not pronouns that a person uses in
relation to themselves unless they're
speaking in the third person
so when she says her pronouns are we and
us she's saying that when you refer to
her
you should call her we and us
which means that you must identify
herself with yourself
she is now include she's included with
you in you
so if i wanted to say catherine watkins
went to the store she's telling me that
i could say
we went to the store now i'm suddenly at
the store too whether i want it to be or
not
this is schizophrenic madness coming
from a woman who teaches eighth grade
students
in a different time in place she'd be in
a straitjacket in a mental asylum
in our time in place she's in a
classroom
and it only gets worse from there so
let's keep listening
i'm gonna say something that's not nice
and not sweet
but it's true if you're not
evolving into an anti-racist educator
you're making yourself obsolete in this
field of profession our district is only
getting browner and browner with our
children and so if you know obviously
you can't change your melanin
all right but you can change your mind
so that you can actually
function in a district that is
full of bipolar children
so if you're being resistant i
understand that
but you're going to have to eventually
come to the light
because if you're going to keep with
those old views
of um colonialism um
it's going to lead to being fired
because you're going to be doing damage
to our children
um trauma and so as we fire the teachers
who sexually abuse our children we will
be firing
the the teachers who do racist things to
our children and traumatize them
and while our district might not be
completely on there
oh um oea is working on all right nea
is working on it and so it's just a
matter of time
so it's like you either evolve or
dissolve
you've got to start walking with us
come to the light evolve or dissolve
by the way what is she wearing on her
head this is a white woman isn't that
cultural appropriation
maybe she identifies as black uh but
there it is any teacher who
resists critical race theory any teacher
who does not espouse far-left viewpoints
and indoctrinate children into those
same viewpoints is tantamount to a
sexual abuser according to catherine
watkins
schizophrenic 8th grade teacher you are
molesting a child
by not brainwashing them and what's
worse
we both hold that view i hold that view
to i don't want to hold that view but i
am her and she is me she she is also you
remember she identifies as you which
means that you are now just as insane as
her hopefully you're following the logic
here i'm not really but
now you might want to soothe yourself by
saying well come on this is oregon we're
talking about
yeah this is oregon this is also
everywhere
the modern public school system is built
on the notion that your kids
belong to it that it has more authority
over your kids than you do
that its job is not to only teach the
abcs of one two threes
but to inculcate a world view into your
child
again the system is built on that
premise it is ingrained
right down to the cellular cellular
level
and we also know that the system in fact
all of our cultural institutions but
especially the academic institutions
are far left and getting further left as
time goes on
send your kids to government schools and
you send them into an institution
whose primary goal in relation to your
child is to turn him into catherine
watkins
in fact he already is kathryn watkins as
again she identifies as him
there's no getting around the conclusion
that there's no avoiding what needs to
be done
we have to give up on the public school
system
it needs us in order to survive remember
without us
it starves to death you're
if every single person who doesn't agree
with what catherine watkins just said
there
stopped sending their kids to public
school you think the public school
system exists
a year from now no your children are the
food
which sustains it so
save your children from being devoured
let the beast
starve to death and then go and dance
around its decayed emaciated corpse
that's what we should do with the public
schools and that's only step one
now let's get to our five headlines
one thing i like about living closer to
a city now there's not a lot i like
about it but one thing i like is that if
i ever need to
call an uber or something i can do it
because i'm not living out in the sticks
anymore
uh five hours from from civilization but
the bad thing about getting into the
back of a car for me is that i get a lot
of motion sickness and uh that has been
a problem for me until i discovered
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraine
hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is uh
drug-free it's non-drowsy enough to
worry about being drowsy and out of it
for the rest of the day
and it provides all-natural relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
i use it
my my daughter uses it as well the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients but now through
relief band it's available to the masses
so
you can ensure that nausea is never the
reason to miss out on life's important
moments
right now relief pat has an exclusive
offer just for matt walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com use promo
code while she'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping
and no questions ask 30 day money-back
guarantee so go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n
and use our promo code walsh for 20 off
so it may shock you uh to learn i'm sure
you you
are not expecting this can be very
surprising but
apparently twitter is not
very serious about um tamping down on
harassment
and uh unsafe behavior
it turns out you know i i know that
again it's gonna be shocking to you so
um a couple days ago my wife who's on
twitter
tweeted something saying in fact i have
it here she said
pretty pretty shocking and uh divisive
stuff she said happy eighth birthday to
our twins
trying to treasure all the moments
uh my wife generally far too sweet for
twitter
far too nice um but that's it she just
because it was my our twin's
eighth birthday a couple days ago and so
a guy responds
um a guy with uh his by the way in his
profile photo i don't know if this is
actually him or not in the photo it
could co
for all i know it is and who knows but
he's holding a gun in his uh profile
photo
and he responds he responds and says
demon spawn
won't see 16 referring to my kids
saying they're not going to see the age
of 16. explicit threat
obviously explicit threat threatening to
kill my kids
and then he goes on from there in fact
there's he's he's goes on harassing my
wife and talking about
how my kids are gonna die and so on this
is
not the first time that my kids have
been threatened happens a lot actually
and i can also tell you by the way that
um and i know that there are there are
bad people on
on every side and all of that
but i have at various points in my
career
been at odds with people on the right
and groups of people
on the right and i've had very angry
very angry people on the right coming
after me
um and sending me messages and saying
horrible things about me it's happened
many times in fact i've gotten death
threats
even from people who would identify as
being on the right
but what i can tell you is that
every single person who has threatened
harm to my children and there have been
a lot of them
every single time it is someone on the
left
every time i don't think that's a
coincidence
and i can't help but think about that
every single time i hear someone laugh
talk about tolerance and all of this
kind of thing of course
i i don't i wouldn't need this kind of
experience to know that the tolerance
stuff is bs
but i can't help but think oh really
then why are you people constantly
threatening to kill
my children because you disagree with my
opinions
anyway so uh my wife reported that to
twitter
and they sent an email back reported
once again
someone threatening to kill my kids um
or
like at best if you wanted the most
generous interpretation
of that tweet is this guy is calling my
kids demon spawn
and wishing death on them
which you would think would qualify at a
minimum as harassment
that you wouldn't that that would be
banned on twitter but uh twitter
sent an email back to my wife pretty
quickly and said we're writing to let
you know that after reviewing the
available information we
didn't find a violation of our rules in
the content you reported
we appreciate that you let us know what
happened and encourage you to reach out
again in the future
if you see any potential violations
now um i then publicly shamed twitter by
putting this out their screenshot of the
tweet and the email
and what do you know after i sent that
out there and the tweet kind of went
viral
um now the account's been suspended it
turns out that they
they reassessed their rules and realized
that oh okay
maybe it did violate our rules
but this is you know i i'm i'm able to
do that with a platform
i can shame twitter and i've had had to
do this more than once
basically shame them into doing the
shame them into doing the right thing
and and abiding by their own rules and
forcing their own rules equally
but if you don't have a platform then
you don't have uh you just don't have
the ability to do it
what twitter wanted to do was uh
and we know this is ideological
they could tell my wife's on the right
this guy's on the left
he threatened to kill her kids and so
they didn't care they're just gonna let
that go
and of course i'm also pursuing legal
avenues as well um
i'm not just this doesn't just go when
you when you make when you threaten my
family
this is not just this this is beyond
twitter now now we have a legal issue
and i'm going to pursue every avenue
available to hold you accountable for
that
but that's um the social media always
looking out always always trying to
fight harassment and everything so great
job great job to twitter
all right and you know what even
there were more more than one person
defend basically defending this guy
um maybe not outright defending it by
saying but saying uh he's
just an internet troll who cares
don't get worked up about internet
trolls this is what i always say to that
to that mentality first of all
yeah you could say whatever you want to
me you threaten my family and
yeah i care it doesn't make a difference
to me if you do it online what it
doesn't count because it's on the
internet
no that's it i care and there's going to
be problems for you if you do that
um but also the
what is an internet troll an internet
troll
is a person who is using the internet
to communicate it's not some magical
land
where the laws of basic decency and
morality
don't count anymore
like this idea that if someone says
something on the internet it doesn't
matter
they're just on the internet so what if
he wrote it on a sheet of paper and
handed it to me
all of a sudden it's worse because of
that because of the method of
communication
it's nonsense if you are and the people
who use this excuse i assume
it's because you yourself are a scumbag
piece of garbage
and you hide behind the anonymity of the
internet to say stuff like this to
people
because you're a coward and you're
trying to justify what you do i just
want you to know
doesn't you are still a scumbag piece of
garbage
just because you're only a scumbag piece
of garbage on the internet
doesn't make you any less of a scumbag
piece of garbage it just makes you more
of a coward on top of it
all right let's move on now um this is
from the post-millennial uh
some some good maybe we could cheer up a
little bit here and a little bit of good
news an atlanta city councilman who
voted to
defund the atlanta police by 73 million
dollars had his car stolen by children
in broad daylight
on wednesday antonio brown who has
mayoral aspirations
was at a ribbon-cutting ceremony when
four kids got into his car and stole it
we have a local news report on this i
think
let's check out there was no care for
loss of life
and for themselves or myself atlanta
councilman and mayoral candidate antonio
brown says
what happened to him in his district in
the dixie hills community in northwest
atlanta
is a perfect example of what is
happening to our youth and why we as a
society
need to step up and help councilman
brown tells fox 5 four young children
stole his white mercedes coop
just before noon wednesday and at the
time he was standing just a few feet
away
speaking with community leader ben
norman one kid was in the driver's seat
ben attempted to open the door to get
him out of the car he fought with ben i
had been
engaged and tried to get him out of the
car the three other kids were trying to
figure out to get in the car or stay out
of the car he started to hit on the gas
ben let go and then the kid started to
drag me in the car
a half of a block generational poverty
has gone on
long enough it's time that we start
addressing the root of this problem
because there's no amount of officers
you're going to put on the streets in
atlanta
that could have stopped this from
happening
really there are no officers that could
have stopped some kids from
getting in a car and stealing it yeah i
i think probably they could
i certainly if there were officers right
there when this happened they could have
stopped it
so yes police officers can they can't
stop all crime
but when you have when you invest more
in policing
and you have more police officers in
these crime-ridden hellhole
neighborhoods
you have less crime funny how that works
and the crime that does happen there's a
better chance of people who do it being
held accountable for it
and the law being enforced again funny
how that works
now as being somewhat facetious i said
this is good news i don't i don't uh
celebrate crime in in any way shape or
form
do i do i care um do i care that
if you if you advocate for defunding the
police officer the police
you want to make neighborhoods less safe
and then you get your car stolen do i
personally care that much do i feel
sorry do i feel sorry for you
no not at all i don't not happy to see
crime ever but i don't feel sorry for
you
i would only call it good news because
it could be an opportunity a learning
opportunity for this guy
maybe he can learn something maybe a
moment of enlightenment
where he understands oh you know what i
need the police right now
turns out the police do serve a purpose
and you know what else
these uh kids were trying to steal my
car
and i i tried to stop them now he he
ties it into judd's generational poverty
well yeah you tried to stop them didn't
you though you didn't wave goodbye and
say okay you can have my car you guys
obviously are suffering from
generational poverty
no you try to physically stop them from
doing this
why because it's a crime they're trying
to take what doesn't belong to them
learning opportunity there maybe you can
start to understand um
why people don't like looting
so you're the kind of person who would
justify looting and on the same basis
probably generational poverty
and they're being oppressed yeah well it
turns out the shop owners are having
their
buildings burned down and their
merchandise
stolen yeah
that that's that's not good enough for
them because
they also are not rich and even if they
are who cares they've got their own
struggles
they're not going to swing open the
doors yeah take whatever you want
any more than you're going to allow
these kids to steal your car
could be a learning opportunity but i
think unfortunately it was a potential
learning opportunity wasted because
from what i understand antonio brown is
still on the defund the police bandwagon
it's defund them you know why it's easy
for him
as a as a as a public official
because he knows that even if you defund
the police and you take police out of
these neighborhoods
whenever he needs them they'll be there
for him and that's all that he
cares about
all right this is from fox it says
conservative watchdog judicial watch has
sued chicago uh chicago mayor lori
lightfoot on behalf of the daily caller
news foundation
over her policy of granting interviews
to only non-white reporters
the lawsuit filed in the united states
district court for northern the northern
district of illinois
alleges that lightfoot violated reporter
thomas katanacci's equal protection
rights under the 14th amendment
when she didn't respond to multiple
requests for interviews as well as his
first amendment rights
and we know that that we talked about
that a few days ago
mayor lightfoot announced that she's
only going to accept interviews from
quote-unquote people of color um and and
we know that uh
that caucasians apparently have no we
are translucent we have no color so we
don't we don't count as people of color
i kind of look at my skin and i think
you know that's a color isn't it it
counts as
some kind of color but no no no i'm uh
i am a hideous translucent beast like
some sort of
deep sea creature anyway so they're
suing and that this is good this is
exactly what needs to happen
we're talking about solutions one step
pull your kids out of public school this
is another important step
take it to court it's not always going
to go the way you want it to obviously
but we got to start taking this stuff to
court this is
obviously blatantly illegal for a public
official an elected representative to
declare
that she's only going to answer
questions and talk to
non-white people obviously illegal and
unconstitutional
and you only need to imagine what would
happen in the reverse and what the
response would be there'd be no
disputing that it's illegal
so we got to start suing over this now i
think there are some people who would
say
that this is frivolous to sue who really
cares and
does the daily caller really want to
talk to um
mayor lightfoot all that much it's not
frivolous
we need to fight tooth and nail at every
point
through every at every avenue available
including legal avenues
that's what the left does that's what
they've been doing
that's how they got to the point they
are now running the culture
fight everything everywhere all the time
through every avenue available
especially when you've got it when
you've got a situation that you know
should be a pretty easy win because what
she's doing is
clearly unconstitutional
same thing needs to happen in the school
system same thing needs to happen at
at these uh in these corporations these
companies where they sit
white student or white uh uh employees
down and berate them on the basis of
their race
subject them to discriminatory and
harassing
treatment there needs to be
lawsuits start suing these people
all right this is uh let's go number
three here caitlyn jenner
now as you know i have not been
a fan of uh caitlyn jenner in general
or his run for for governor of
california a lot of conservatives
jumped on the bandwagon they were really
excited about they were excited about
their chance to say
look the dems are the real transphobes
hey we got you now dems
you see we got we got our own
transgender person they're running on
as a republican what are you going to do
now
we've stumped you now haven't we
and no you haven't the democrats don't
care
because they can easily wave caitlyn
jenner off and say oh yeah well
that doesn't count this is someone who
has internalized
transphobia or whatever whatever thing
um it's not gonna make the democrats
stop and say well you know what hmm i
guess if the republicans have a
transgender candidate they aren't so bad
after all
that's not going to happen it hasn't
worked that way
and the other big problem is that
caitlyn jenner is uh
aside from having no qualifications to
be governor at all
also a leftist a far leftist
holds far left views on almost every
issue certainly almost every issue that
matters
including on the gender stuff which
should be no surprise but kaylen jenner
came out a few days ago maybe
a week or two ago and uh
took a position against having males
in female sports and a lot of
conservatives once again swept off their
feet by that
hey caitlyn jenner is our new hero this
this is a powerful advocate
and i you may recall i said at the time
you cannot trust this
you can't trust this position that
caitlyn jenner is taking here
and uh that seems to be confirmed now
caitlyn jenner was being
interviewed on fox news asked again
about
the uh the the female sports situation
especially in comparison to his previous
statements where he had been in favor of
males and female sports
and here's what he said and you notice i
did not say
in that statement trans women i said
biological boys
what i would do is as governor i would
put together a commission
trans women can compete in the olympics
they compete in the ncaa
but when it gets down to the high school
level there's no guide rules there's no
rules and regulations
how they can and trans women who are
truly trans
who at a very young age you know started
proper medical treatment they've grown
up as girls of course they should be
able to compete in girls sports
but yeah as some guy who hasn't done
any therapy hasn't done anything there
has to be a review board i'd be the
first governor to put together a review
board to review each case
such a small issue it's like a non-issue
that's out there
and i would be surprised if there's 30
trans athletes
in the entire state okay well
there's your conservative hero
conservatives well done
actually caitlyn jenner which should not
be a shock
stakes out not only does it turn out
that he's in favor of female
males and female sports but his his
view on the gender stuff is it's an
extreme view
extreme far left view
because first of all he draws a
distinction between biological men
and trans women he says uh well i said i
i was talking about biological men not
trans women so what he's trying to claim
is that so-called trans women are not
biological men
that's what he just said
that's an extreme view
that's that that doesn't even approach
the realm of
a conservative view or a sane rational
view
what he's saying is that there are he's
allowing
that there i guess i suppose that there
may be some
men who claim to be trans women but are
not and so he wants to have a review
board that's not creepy at all
we'll have some government review board
to um look at each individual case of
every man
claiming to be a woman and this review
board will decide which man is actually
a woman
so he's allowing that there may be cases
like that but
what he's saying is that a real trans
woman is one who is not actually a
biological man
so what are they gender biological women
it's apparently what he thinks and then
he also says worst of all
he says that he thinks any
student who's been on
medication on quote treatment from a
very young
age should be allowed to compete against
the girls
of course they should be allowed it
could be against the goals so what do we
learn from that
we learn not only again is he is he in
favor of males and female sports
but he's in favor of medicating
very young children
and this is this is the person
that so many republicans were excited
about
my god how stupid do you have to be
all right um this is from variety a
little bit of entertainment news
it says audiences are going to be
confronted this weekend with something
they haven't seen in a long time new
movies they may actually want to watch
in theaters and the first box office
battle in aegis paramounts a quiet place
part two
and disney's cruella are expected to
heat up an ice-cold domestic box office
and kick off a delayed summer movie
season the uh sequel to 2018 is a quiet
place starring emily blunt and directed
by her husband john kasich is expected
to pull ahead of its competition
uh and then also there's this cruella
which is what is it's a live-action
origin
story about the famous fur loving
villain from 101 dalmatians
um and uh that's gonna be in theaters
but also on disney plus
so and you could pay you could pay
thirty dollars to rent it on top of your
disney plus subscription
i this in origin i think the movie is
pg-13 so it's a pg-13
origin story of cruella deville for who
is that supposed to be for
i'm not going to have my eight-year-old
kids watching that
a pg-13 origin story explaining
how this woman turned into a serial
killer of dogs
who who so that's not for kill 101
dalmatians
is a kid's movie through and through and
this is not for kids so who's
a bunch of 40 year old adults are going
to sit down and watch this i guess so
but it is it is good anyway i i think
it's um
i'm excited by the prospect of of i'm
not ready to give up on movie theaters
even though they serve no real purpose
anymore
um i i think that's an american
institution that i i
i would be happy to see revived the only
problem is in fact
we um are planning to go see a quiet
place part two
tonight and i got the tickets
and then i got the email with the
tickets and it said in the email and i
kind of wasn't expecting this because
here in nashville i don't nobody wears
masks anywhere anymore i haven't been
asked to wear one and i don't know how
long
but i said the tickets that everyone has
to wear a mask despite what the cdc says
everyone has to wear a mask at all times
even sitting in the auditorium watching
the movie
the only the only stipulation i'd be
interested maybe if anyone anyone knows
anyone who's been to a movie theater
i'm wondering if they really enforce it
or not because the only stipulation is
that uh
unless you're eating then you don't have
to wear it
so i think that i think that means that
i could just sit down with a popcorn and
stuff my face the entire time and i
don't have to wear the mask
which is what i would do anyway
so we'll see but if you actually have to
sit there i mean
this is a good way movie theaters
a good way to make sure that you don't
revive your industry and that you are
forever destroyed
is to actually force the people in the
theaters to wear a mask while they're
sitting there for two and a half hours
watching a movie
who the hell would want to do that well
you could sit at your house without a
mascot
so i'll be i'll be interested to see um
whether we're able to watch the movie or
if we get kicked out because there's no
way there's no scenario where i'm
actually going to sit there with a mask
on and watch watch the movie no movie is
worth that
all right um i guess we have a little
bit of time for this speaking of wearing
a mask
indoors i really wish i could assume
this is fake but
i i can't assume that there's a letter
written to slate's advice column
now the whole idea that anybody would
write a letter to slate's advice column
is already sort of hard to believe
but uh they have a device column and
they get letters and there are a lot of
crazy people out there as we've
discovered
so i i'm i'm leaning towards this is
real
but here's the letter it says i've been
married to a great guy for five and a
half years he's handsome sexy funny and
kind
it's true that he's always been a little
prissy about illnesses but i never
thought it was a real problem however
during the pandemic his terror about
getting sick
has reached new levels for the last year
he has refused to take off his face mask
even when we're at home just the two of
us this is true even now that he's fully
vaccinated for the virus
he wears it to sleep to do most of his
bathroom activities and yes even during
love making
to eat he pulls it up to expose his
mouth and then quickly pulls it back
down between bites
well he doesn't insist that i do the
same i can tell it bothers him
especially because i have now started
going maskless outside
but i've tried to present him with the
science he says scientists don't fully
understand the virus yet or
i know it probably isn't necessary but
wearing it makes doesn't bother me so if
there's even a small chance they can
protect us i'd rather be on the safe
side
i disagree that there's no harm i want
to see my beautiful husband's face again
i want to kiss him on the lips
romantically like we used to
and not through a piece of fabric he
doesn't change his mask very often and
it's often smelly and soiled oh my gosh
i'm going to vomit and i don't want to
feel judged by him
uh by him for my own behavior which i
consider reasonable
and uh anyway she then she asks what
she's supposed to do
i mean what what you should do what you
should be able to do is have this guy i
mean
in all seriousness this is someone who
should be committed into a mental asylum
and i don't say that as
joke or as hyperbole this is really a
a crazy person with a with a severe
mental illness
who who needs to be in a in some sort of
facility
for his own safety and those around him
this is not someone
suited for living in civilized society
that's the real answer but uh
unfortunately
that's probably not an option because
the medical industry is not going to
recognize this
as an illness at any other time they
would you know pre-covet if there was a
guy
wearing a mask all the time and never
taking it off
it would be agreement among all health
professionals mental health
professionals that this is a this is
someone with
severe debilitating ocd and they need to
be in a facility
but now it's been normalized and i'm
afraid like i said i wish i could i wish
i could assume this is fake but there
are
a lot of people i think who are if not
this bad close to it
i'm not someone who who puts a lot of
effort into how i look
which probably is obvious but that's why
i like
that's why i like mac weldon because
with mac weldon they bring
comfort and style and they just make it
really easy on
on someone like me a slob like myself
because i just put on mac weldon and i
know that i'll look good
trust me your closet is going to thank
you if you go with mac welding whether
it's their hoodies polos tees or active
shorts everything in the mac weldon
collection mixes and matches seamlessly
to fit in with any other trendy products
you have
whether it's socks shirts hoodies
underwear polos
whatever it is it's a comfort and it's
also a consistent fit
from working out going out going to work
going on a date whatever it is mac
weldon
is for everyday life they have a wide
range of customized fabrics that can
keep
up with you no matter what your day
looks like and uh no matter what you're
doing there's a there's a mac welding
product that will fit for that
so you got to try this out and here's
the good news for 20
off your first order you could visit
macweldon.com walsh and enter promo code
walsh that's macweldon.com
promo code walsh for 20 off mack weldon
reinventing men's basics
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments
um this one says if more people were
like matt walsh the world would be a
better and smarter place well you know i
i agree it's what i've been saying thank
you
um matt you always scream at us that we
should like the video but why don't you
tell us to subscribe to your channel
that's really good points
so subscribe to the channel subscribe
right now
um we'll see if that works uh let's see
hey matt i'm just wondering how you plan
to enforce the bans
on your show i mean what happens if a
banned person comes back and watches
anyway well then i'll send someone to
your home
and have you killed just kidding um
i was just complaining about death
threats
uh not not a very good transition there
let's see this was as i watched the dw
backstage and i totally agree with walsh
he annihilated the others on the alien
argument
matt's most convincing argument though
is that not believing in aliens is
boring
and that really is when it comes down to
it mostly my argument
it's the most fun thing to believe and
in this case
i will go with i will let my emotions
guide me on this
emotions over facts feelings over facts
when it comes to aliens anyway
you know if anyone is known for
destroying leftist fallacies it's me
um oh wait no no it's ben shapiro
ben shapiro is known for that and if you
want to listen to him do it in 15
minutes or less then you're
in for a treat because every saturday an
audio episode of his new series debunked
is dropping daily wire members can get
the full 10 uh episode
first season over dailywire.com but if
you're not already a member you get 20
off today with code debunked while the
discount lasts on tomorrow's
podcast episode he takes on biden's
covid lies and explains why everything
his administration has done in the wake
of the pandemic
was not for the the this for safety or
public health or anything but rather for
political gain
and he lays it all out quickly and
in a way that's really easy to
understand so you want to check that out
and you can get it on your podcast feed
at apple spotify or wherever
your platform of choice happens to be
also it's your last chance to enter to
win a free trip for
to daily wire studios to meet candace
owens and see her
live show if you sign up now as a daily
wire member with code vip you'll get 20
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip
4-2 to the daily wire studios to see
matt walsh live oh wait no
candace left none of this is about me uh
the deal ends on memorial day so don't
wait another minute not only will you be
meeting candace but you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio and front row
seats to watch her take down leftist
live
and in action on her talk show so again
you don't want to miss out on this this
is your last chance
enter now to win two vip tickets to to a
candice
um show with a canvas vip pass now at
dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today we cancel pink news which is a gay
news outlet
based in the uk um you'll be i'm sure
shocked to discover that the people who
work for a british gay news site called
pink news apparently are not fans of
yours truly me of all people i can't
imagine what sort of problem they could
have with me
in fact pink news has in recent years
written several outraged articles
attacking me for some of the things i've
said on this very show
i'm not ashamed to admit that each time
they publish an article like that i
openly weep as i read it
because all i want is for everyone to
like me that should be obvious to anyone
who listens to the show my main goal is
to say
really popular mainstream things it's
just that i'm bad at it
which brings us to the latest from pink
news the headline is daily wire's matt
walsh compares trans health care to
pedophilia and nazi science in
disgusting rant
disgusting pink news i am a person with
feelings too you know
anyway the article says the daily wires
matt walsh has publicly compared trans
healthcare to experimentation
molestation abuse and rape in an episode
of his podcast the matt wall show
released on monday titled the evil
quacks mutilating our children
walsh went on a 20-minute rant about
gender ideology actually it was like 17
or 18 months
in fairness wall street thinks the use
of face masks to curb the spread of
chronovirus has created a society of
adults who fear breathing fresh air
said that trans youth should not receive
gender affirming healthcare because they
literally can't make good long-term
decisions
he continued quote this is also why we
say adolescents can't consent to sex
um dr johanna olsen kennedy wants to
undermine the legal scientific and
philosophical case against pedophilia
um and that's not a coincidence by the
way check back in 10 years or maybe
sooner and she'll be explaining with
equal passion why we must be tolerant
towards adult child sexual relationships
uh gender affirming health care for
trans youth is vital in reducing mental
health problems and suicidal ideation
has been backed by
every major major medical association
okay let's pause here for a moment
now most of what they've written so far
is true i did say
what they've quoted me as saying i i
said all of that because it's true i
don't apologize for it
and i don't wish to moderate or water
down my points at all i said what i said
and i meant it
um we run into problems though in that
last paragraph
where it says again gender affirming
health care for trans youth is vital in
reducing mental health problems and
suicidal ideation
and has been backed by every major
medical association
two major issues here first there's the
term gender affirming health care
and the second is there's the claim that
drugging and mutilating children is the
best way to stop them from killing
themselves
as for the first thing you may notice
how
there is no other context where
surgeries and quote health care
are administered to affirm something now
to affirm means to state as a fact or
assert strongly
it can also mean offering emotional
support and encouragement
since when have you ever heard of an
emotionally supportive
surgery now you may say that all
cosmetic surgery sort of fits that bill
but nobody calls a nose job
a nose-affirming surgery and besides
gender ideologues would say that gender
affirming procedures quote-unquote
are not merely cosmetic
so the question remains when have you
heard of a medical procedure
that has the purpose of affirming when
have you heard of
medicine whose purpose is to make or
support an assertion
in fact when have you even heard of a
therapist whose primary goal is simply
to affirm that is encourage
or assert as fact whatever their
patients say to them
the goal of a therapist is supposed to
be oftentimes the opposite of that
and the goal of surgery and medicine is
to treat or heal an ailment
or an injury or a disease it's not to
affirm anything
now the gender ideologues aren't simply
misusing medicine
they're attempting to turn it on its
head they seek to fundamentally redefine
the very purpose of medicine just as
they seek to redefine sex and biology
and they seek to do this while
pretending that they aren't doing
anything radical or extreme at all
indeed they seek to do it while scoffing
at anyone who raises the slightest
objection
they've come along subverted millennia
of human experience wisdom and knowledge
and they insist not only that we allow
them to do it but that we don't even
raise a question about
it and most people seem willing to
comply with those demands i'm not and i
never will be
never not ever i will continue to insist
on the truth
the truth that all of us and all people
everywhere have always known up until 19
seconds ago
one of those truths is that there are
only males and females that's it that's
all there are a small minority of people
who suffer birth defects
that affect the appearance of their
genitalia which has nothing to do with
transgenderism anyway but still there
are only two sexes no other human sexes
have ever been discovered or ever will
be
another truth is that the purpose of
medicine is still despite what the
gender ideal
ideologues claim to treat and heal
so when a physically healthy young girl
is put on puberty blockers than hormones
and under breasts are chopped off
what physical ailment is being treated
what is the disease that these doctors
are trying to suppress or cure
you can't say that they're treating
gender dysphoria because gender
dysphoria is a mental condition just
like anorexia is a mental condition
you don't treat mental conditions by
altering the body to coincide more
closely with the patient's delusional
mental state
that's not how you heal mental illness
so again
what disease is being treated by
chopping off a girl's healthy breasts
womanhood is that the disease
well whether the gender ideologues will
say it out loud or not that is
how they see it that womanhood or
manhood is the disease and i would call
that pretty disgusting
speaking of disgusting the the emotional
blackmail that these people use
is not only disgusting but simply evil
they say that we must drug and mutilate
kids um
or else the kids will kill themselves
they say studies prove them right
they're lying these people are liars and
everything they say
everything should be ignored in fact
studies show
that suicide rates amongst among trans
people remain sky high
after surgery but that's not even the
point the point is that we just now
started doing this kind of thing to
thousands of kids all at once
when the under when the gender
ideologues start talking about all the
studies proving the efficacy and safety
of their procedures
you know they're lying because there
can't have been any reliable long-term
studies on this subject there hasn't
been a large enough sample size to study
yet
this current crop of children they are
the guinea pigs
the mad scientists are running
experiments on them
they're one big test group the
assumption
the claim the hope is the assertion
is that drugging them and chopping off
their body parts will work out well in
the long term
there is no data to support that
assumption there can't be
and any sane person's common sense and
moral intuition
militates against those assumptions
well maybe i'm wrong a little bit there
was one long-term study that comes to
mind one experiment conducted decades
ago whose results can now be observed as
i've mentioned before john money
tested these gender theories that he
came up with on two young boys in the
1970s
and how did that go well both of them
went on to kill themselves
so those were the long-term results
and these are the facts pink news
doesn't want to hear the facts
they don't want you to hear the facts
either which is why they ended their hit
piece this way quote
walsh's social media posts about the
podcast on facebook youtube and twitter
remain live
and his podcast remains available
through apple podcast despite each
platform having policies against hate
speech
he also remains verified on twitter
facebook and youtube
pink news has approached facebook
youtube twitter and apple for comments
well of course they have they know their
position is indefensible
they know it they know everything i'm
saying is 100 obviously true
they have no counter argument no
rebuttal none nothing
all they could do is run to the
principal's office and try to get me
suspended or expelled
and maybe they'll succeed eventually i
don't know
but that won't change the truth and it
won't stop me from speaking it
and it also won't stop me from saying to
pink news you're canceled
that'll do it for the day and the week
have a great weekend
what's the word oh yeah godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel valdoski the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 21. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin